[Music]
we do it every night there you go every
night and that must be why you've been
together 20 years it's the only reason
why it's the only reason why don't share
a bathroom don't share a bathroom is a
great that's my best advice laugh if
they stop making you laugh then your
days are numbered
yeah Freddy and Sarah Michelle's rules
for a happy marriage seem to be working
just fine 20 years and two kids later
they even have us laughing talking about
12 year old daughter Charlotte and
nine-year-old son Rocky when they're
good they take after me and when they're
being naughty they take after Freddy
obviously
but the couple's biggest secret to
Everlasting Love I'm the cook in our
house you are yeah so you can boil wine
everything that's why my wife married me
because I cook and clean most of the
time so any opportunity I clean who
cooks and cleans more I said I cleaned
with a sneaky smile you said it food and
food and funny that's our that's those
are our secrets right food and funny
food and funny
could be anywhere for him Freddie and
Sarah Michelle first met in 1997 on the
set of I Know What You Did Last Summer
but they were just friends for three
years before things ever got romantic
it's my goal to entertain the world
through artistic expression in between
Sarah Michelle dated Jerry O'Connell and
was rumored to be seeing her Buffy the
Vampire Slayer co-star David Boreanaz it
is never over
meanwhile her friend Freddy dated
General Hospital star Kimberly
McCullough and side note while he's a
heartthrob now things weren't always
that way I was a dork man my first three
years in high school I think I got
turned down by like every girl I asked
out
Freddy and Sarah Michelle hung out a lot
before ever making things official
that's how she scored her cameo in his
1999 movie She's All That she was on set
so much producers gave her a part
Brown pepper
but by 2000 they were coupled up and
making their red carpet debut at the MTV
Movie Awards I got my girl my boy I'm as
happy as Kimberly she won best kiss when
Selma Blair which was very strange
because uh
we both kissed her
and it was just kind of weird to watch
them go up there and accept that Awards
I don't know how I feel about that yeah
Freddie and Sarah Michelle went on to
star in both Scooby-Doo movies together
as Fred and Daphne there's no such thing
as ghosts but after six movies together
don't expect to see these two
co-starring again anytime soon I don't
think it's very interesting on screen I
mean I know at home we're pretty boring
you've had dinner with us we're pretty
boring I don't think it's great on
screen she's being very humble right now
well boring or not Sarah Michelle and
Freddie are still relationship goals to
us you guys have got to be the best
looking couple and I mean that here
tonight
oh man I believe he can do anything but
the fact that he went out there and he
wrote and produced his first idea and
here we are
co-wrote I've been right about myself
she's better at that saying good stuff
about me than that everybody just wants
to fall in love right and then it's
about keeping them until they get sick
of you that what happens I don't know
we're not there
[Music]